[Music]
Bud Light apparently still has not
learned its lesson because Bud Light
according to reports is still going to
sponsor three Pride events Bud Light is
listed as a sponsor of the Cincinnati
Pride Parade a Planned Parenthood and
the Cincinnati Children's Hospital which
transes little kids are both also listed
for that one in St Louis where
transheiser bush is headquartered they
are a presenting sponsor the presenting
sponsor of the St Louis Pride Parade the
rainbow sponsorship tier which is below
the presenting sponsor tier requires 25
Grand in in donations to the LGBT
elementop gestapo so who knows how much
transheiser bush is paying there and
then they're also listed as a diamond
sponsor of Stonewall Columbus which
organizes and hosts the annual Columbus
Ohio Pride Parade